make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and we are back again with the
events of
joker war this time we're on part three
and if i'm being honest with you guys
i think we are getting what is more or
less
a new red hood and i'll explain what i
mean here in a minute because there's
red hood as you guys know him and then
there's jason todd the way he originally
was which i feel like only the most
die-hard fans would probably know but
this initially picks up in tri-corner
yards right basically the shipyards in
gotham city and we basically got
punchline now again this is one of the
things that i love that james henyan's
doing with punchline with harley quinn
this is something that's kind of
interesting with harley quinn she was
the sidekick of the joker but more in so
far
she was like the comic relief as well as
the one that was designed to kind of
maintain the sex appeal
with punchline sure she's somewhat drawn
in that way but she's a lot more
hands-on in terms of like the joker's
ongoing
operations making sure things run like
she's like a field commander more or
less it's kind of what you would expect
but i do really like the nature of
punchline
one of the big things that kind of goes
into this though is that with all these
containers being moved this is all part
of the joker toxin right that the joker
basically plans to use
on the city of gotham the problem with
this is that the henchmen of the joker
are a little uncertain about going into
what's basically the narrows
right like the the shady part of town
and you wouldn't really expect that of
the joker henchmen
they're literally criminals and thugs
right like if anybody was going to be at
home in the narrows it would be these
guys but there's something
in the narrows that scares the crap out
of them and what we end up doing is
picking up with the with the narrows the
day before right in this this
neighborhood and we pick up with clown
hunter now this is kind of the cool
thing this is why i say this guy
i think is kind of like the new jason
todd right like the new red hood so what
you end up having
was a couple of the henchmen of the
joker who were basically driving the
batmobile or at least one version of the
batmobile and clown hunter ended up
tracking them down
and then basically you know
incapacitated the vehicle using like a
fire hydrant
right because it's like electrically
powered and so on so this guy basically
figures out a way to short circuit the
batmobile which if i'm being honest with
you guys
kind of on the fence about right i feel
like if batman were gonna create a
vehicle designed to basically allow him
to fight prime in the city of gotham one
of the first things he would think of
is what happens if it gets wet what
happens if it's raining outside but
that's kind of the cool thing right this
kid's ingenuity because it wasn't simply
just
water that led to this thing being being
you know being short-circuited it was
him bringing like a portable transformer
and that's all it really took
right just like an electrical base some
water and then like a huge surge of
electricity and so with this thing being
being incapacitated he ends up cracking
one of the windows and then pours
gasoline inside and sets it on fire and
the guys burn alive the reason why i say
i feel like this guy is the is the new
red hood
is because when it comes to jason todd
there's two versions of his character
there's jason todd as he was originally
created then there's jason todd the
character who he became after the events
of crisis on infinite earth so
in the original appearances of jason
todd while you didn't necessarily see
him do anything
as hardcore as this there was an
instance where he actually
pushed a criminal off a ledge now by the
time batman got up there the criminal
had fallen
and the response to jason todd was well
you know i mean he fell there was
nothing i could do but it was heavily
alluded to that jason pushed him over
right like jason was the reason that guy
died and it was kind of given to us that
jason was not dick grayson right dick
grayson was the guy like he was a
believer right like he believed in the
cause of batman and he fought alongside
batman you know until he decided to go
on to become nightwing that kind of a
thing but he never would have gone down
that darker path
jason todd did and that was something
that fans didn't like my fans didn't
like the idea of jason todd becoming
more extreme more intense combined with
the fact that his origin was basically
identical to dick grayson's right they
saw him as like a darker
carbon copy of dick grayson himself and
so that's why he went to the post-crisis
landscape dc changed his origin
fans still hated him so they got him
they basically killed him off but jason
todd was
very very dark in his early appearances
in in dc comics right and that's what
this feels like right this feels like
jason todd the way he originally was and
and that's why i say i think this is
important because i have a hard time
believing that some character named
clown hunter that's given a name by
james tinians
established in terms of who this guy is
and he's tracking down the various
villains of the joker that he's killing
them off everywhere that he can find
them i have a hard time believing this
kid's just going to kind of be thrown
away
what i think is going to happen is that
at the end of all this he's going to be
taken under batman's wing and he's going
to become
the new robin maybe maybe not the new
robin person maybe just kind of like a
different name but it's going to lead to
like damian wayne probably you know
continuing to be robin but doing his
thing on the teen titans and this guy
becoming the new sidekick of batman
right i'm not really sure how that'll go
down but that's kind of what it feels
like but what it leads to is it leads to
punchline basically saying okay fine if
this is the case i'll go and track this
person down myself or get a hold of the
joker or whatever
but like your job is to get this to his
destination if you have to go around the
narrows then go around the narrows but
if it's not where it needs to be in time
then you guys are going to be the ones
i'm going to point the finger to and do
you really want the joker coming after
you because you missed your shipment
make your choice but make sure you
choose wisely now the other part of this
is it switches over to batman dealing
with this movie theater full of all
these corpses and the joker hits in and
this is something that i love the most
so this is why i love what james
tinian's doing with batman
you end up having the joker talking to
bruce wayne right you know he's kind of
been taunting him giving him a bit of a
hard time while batman's dealing with
all this and he says you know i wonder
which one of these
of these people hate you more right
because like these are all corpses of
people who have died at my hands i
wonder which ones hate you more
the ones who basically died at the very
beginning of all this when you
underestimated how many people would die
in all of our conflicts or the ones who
died recently
knowing the longer i was out there the
more people i would kill
and that's the coolest line of logic
because that's one of the things that
i've always kind of said about batman
that while people will say well batman
doesn't kill right that's the rule of
batman the question becomes like is it a
good rule to have
right just because it's a rule doesn't
mean that it's a good rule and when
you're talking about so many bystanders
being killed on a regular basis then
what it does is it allows you to shine
batman in different lights but you can
you can shine batman in a more positive
light and say see he's a good hero he
doesn't kill but then you can shine him
in what's really a more realistic light
and say yeah but his villains do and for
every villain that he leads that that
basically gets out onto the streets and
batman believes in this rehabilitation
tactic and then in turn gets these
villains back into arkham asylum knowing
they're probably going to escape or
they're going to get back out they're
probably going to end up killing some
people then it turns into is batman
really doing gotham any good because if
he knows the villains are going to
escape but he won't kill them and he
knows the villains are going to kill
people
batman is in effect sacrificing innocent
lives for his belief that he can
rehabilitate
you know villains like the joker that's
basically what it is right the
rehabilitation of the joker is more
important in the life of the average
person we know that by virtue of
batman's actions and that's that's
that's what makes this discussion in
this debate so cool
is batman really a good hero can you
really call yourself a good hero
if you willingly and knowingly sacrifice
the lives of innocent people in order to
try to fix a villain there has to come a
time when you basically say okay enough
is enough i'm not willing to sacrifice
any more innocent lives for you like i
will break my code for this like sure
it'll make me as bad as you but the city
will be better for it it's an amazing
little little philosophy here that the
joker has kind of pointing at that
fallacy of batman right like look at all
these innocent people that i've killed
and think of all the innoce the other
innocent people that i'm going to kill
because i'm going to make all of them
relive your experience i'm literally
paying them to come to this theater and
they're going to watch the mask of zorro
and they're going to have the time of
their life and then i'm going to start
pumping my joker toxin in here and
they're going to die and they're going
to be reanimated with these nanites as
one of my henchmen right so they have no
idea it's coming but we're going to do
this
over and over and over and over again
it's awesome
i think that the way the joker is being
handled here is amazing because i think
one of the biggest problems the joker
has
over the years in dc comics is the
joker's only ever really shown
in in one of like two or three different
ways you're either given the super silly
joker from like steve englehart you get
like the silly and the sadistic joker
which is what you got back in like the
40s with bob kane and bill finger when
he first popped up or you get like the
scott snyder new 52
just crazy twisted joker but to have
this version here
who's kind of like a combination of all
of them right like he's he's silly he's
twisted but he's also
incredibly dark makes this some of the
best joker storytelling that i've read
in a long long time and that's my
question which version of the joker do
you guys like more do you like the one
from like the new 52 batman run
or do you like this version because i'll
be honest with you guys i kind of like
this version more
right like i love the way it's drawn and
i love the way he acts and i love his
plan
i really dig that now the other thing
here is remember while batman is
hallucinating because of this toxin he
is feeding on it right so alfred's been
dead alfred's been dead since the events
uh since he was killed during city of
bain
during tom king's batman run and so
batman you know basically hallucinating
alfred is a way for him to essentially
control this hallucination
hallucination experience that he's
having to control all of that now where
his mind and where the joker kind of
starts getting into his head and he
actually starts to hallucinate
all these different people who are
coming after him as jokers right when in
reality they're just you know corpses
essentially batman's able to basically
issue an emp
that will take out his earpiece so he
won't really be able to hear alfred
anymore quote unquote and
of course it'll take out the nanites
that are controlling all these corpses
they basically kind of have them coming
back right because they're not truly
reanimated undead
it's not like night of the living dead
kind of stuff going on here it's not
really like a biological agent or
anything along those lines but once
batman makes his way out of the theater
and then collapses while
hallucinating his parents he's rescued
by harley quinn again now this is where
the joker gets cool it's because what we
end up doing is jumping back to him
right we've got punchline showing up
here and basically saying hey
there's this kid out there in the
narrows that's basically taking out our
henchmen right taking out our guys and
where she thinks the joker is gonna
respond with like being pissed off and
throwing stuff around
instead like the joker's excited about
it and when she asks why she's like why
would you be so happy about this he's
like because this is truly chaos that
we're finally seeing right we're finally
seeing chaos happening that whenever you
saw like batgirl or or
for the most part in more recent years
the red hood and even the red hood was a
little sketchy but whenever you saw like
damien wayne you know like robin or you
saw tim drake or you saw dick grayson
you saw some other member of the bat
family it was
we don't kill right like we'll beat you
within an inch of your life but we won't
really go past that inch
you know we don't kill people it was
always the rule of gotham but now
we've got true chaos out here we've got
people who don't follow the rules of
batman anymore you got people out there
taking the law into their own hands
because there's nobody else out there to
maintain law in order and so it's like
this is true chaos now like this is this
is what i was hoping for this is what i
was looking for and so the response is
like okay
i mean do we let this guy live and keep
doing his thing and the joker's like of
course not kill him like crucify the guy
so people know that he can't do that but
it's just cool to see
this is one of the one of the funny
little joker moments uh what what he
ends up telling like
he kind of makes this this comment a
punch line like it's time for me to
finally basically off harley quinn right
to get rid of harley quinn punchline
loves that because now she feels like
she's actually the number one in the
joker's life which as we know by virtue
of harley quinn's experience
that's not always the case but then you
have batman who kind of wakes up in like
this crazy wonky looking place who's
like lit
by by a dog and he's like ace ace is
that you oh buddy
buddy i've missed you so much i haven't
seen you in so long asa it's like yeah
it's me
ace the bat hound and then it turns out
it's harley quinn
i love that i love i i saw that i
probably laughed for a solid two minutes
right like i thought that was hilarious
but anyway batman basically wakes up and
harley quinn says this place is eden and
this is a cool little expansion here she
really says that like within the city of
gotham
there's little secrets and little
hideouts little places that you don't
know about
where us various villains get together
and we meet or we relax and recuperate
this is awesome you know up and and i
think this is a lot of ways
building on snyder's batman run and
that's why the new 52 batman run by
scott snyder was just the stuff of
legend
because it did these small little things
where it introduced elements whether
they were huge or small that changed the
way that we saw batman because we always
thought of bruce wayne as like the caped
crusader right the guy who knows
knows gotham like the back of his hand
and then you get in a new 52 and it's
like there's this criminal enterprise
that's been operating in the city of
gotham for hundreds of years and batman
never knew about it and then you go here
into james tinion and it's like there's
these small little nooks and crannies
batman doesn't know about it shows how
ingenuitive the criminals are like it
shows how intelligent they are and like
finding places like they
know batman's haunts so they know which
places to go to and they know which
places to avoid
and it's cool to have that right because
apparently poison ivy put all this
together and initially it was made for
harley quinn when
seemingly she left joker at one period
in time and was struggling with their
their split right with their separation
and it was designed to basically help
her relax
and always help her to help her kind of
get away from things she ends up feeding
batman this kind of cocktail and says
this will basically
flush the entire toxin out of your
system but be aware man it's going to
take you for one hell of a ride
harley's quinn's harley quinn like her
face turns into the joker it's
like her neck snaps sideways it just
gets wonky batman starts losing his mind
and it's like okay like this like none
of this is real and then suddenly he's
met by the arrival of alfred and it's
like you know i'm very sorry master
bruce but like i think it's time that we
have a very serious talk now we know
alfred's not actually here but what this
feels like it's going to do
is go into alfred and batman and really
kind of batman more or less having a
conversation with himself and it's going
to elevate his character and i'm
very very excited to see what this what
this comic's going to be about but with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you